during a thousands of Coney Isle are getting
a first-hand view what a couple of small boys in
a fun fire under the boardwalk started in
this famous resort skeleton drones and tons
of debris are all the remain of four blocks
of dwellings and concessions hundreds are
homeless and it will take millions of dollars
to restore this section to normal activity in
the bath houses that were destroyed clothes
and other belongings if an army of bathers
went up in smoke including money and jewelry
check for safekeeping in answer to reports at
their Vince and wise loss a thorough search
will corner over the flames swept area for
possible victims scores of parked autos were
caught in a faculty place but meanwhile extra
visitors blocking in to gaze at the wreckage are
making business boom in the untouched section
they say it's an ill wind that blows nobody any
good and that seems to go over stone fires too